welcome back to the Leia heilpan show
joining me today for the second time but
this time in person is YouTuber crypto
Enthusiast and founder of bit boy crypto
it is Ben Armstrong Ben welcome to the
show how are you yeah doing great
obviously it's uh Bitcoin maximalist
week right so uh we're here in Miami and
uh you know super excited about
everything going on this week I've had a
lot going on the last uh you know little
period here on Twitter and stuff like
that and you know really I got these
lawsuits going on and I've got all kinds
of stuff
um can't wait to start getting into that
oh yeah I'm gonna ask you every yeah
let's
let's I know you do
you just week it is Bitcoin Maxi week it
is uh the Bitcoin conference so tell me
what are your plans this week well I've
got some super secret plans that
everybody at the conference is going to
find out about on Thursday and Friday so
uh really excited about that um I really
like the uh the Taproot Wizards the
ordinals on bitcoin like Udi and Eric so
we're gonna go support them when they
speak the Bitcoin conference only people
I care about see and speak uh we bought
100 wizard hats to hand out uh because
we love the idea of bringing the fun
back to bitcoin getting rid of the laser
eyes Maxis oh you don't like that yeah
well you know the funny thing is over
time they just kind of go away because
they're like the woke crowd they create
so many rules for themselves they can't
possibly follow it so one of the rules
was you weren't allowed to do ordinals
so now Bitcoin magazine they did
ordinals and so now they're like kind of
out on the outs with the Bitcoin
maximums crew so be interested to see
what happens next year with the uh the
Bitcoin conference but got a lot of
events uh charity poker tournament gonna
be doing on Saturday
um you know Thursday night whale night
obviously going to be going to the uh uh
to the next crypto gym party I think
I'll see you there hopefully
um and uh you know a few other things
gonna go to the Cynthia Lumis uh dinner
okay uh try to see her and then I'm
going to be sending some people try to
make a stop uh to see Robert Kennedy Jr
as well oh yeah they have an amazing
lineup um yeah Kennedy's gonna be out
which is amazing but a lot of a lot of
entertainment and friction I expect from
you this week so I'm really excited but
you mentioned the next crypto gem that's
actually where we met in person for the
very first time it was about two months
ago back in La so it's it was great to
meet you in person so tell me what was
your involvement with the next crypto
gem how did it go for you yeah so it was
really exciting so
um my role was kind of towards the end
of the show as it gets down to the
nitty-gritty they bring on three whales
um you know it was uh me I don't know if
I want to say who the other people are
um am I allowed to say it I I feel like
no I'm gonna go with no yeah everybody
knows I'm on the show so yeah um I can
talk about myself so me and two other
whales uh at least one of them is pretty
popularly known across uh the world for
something specific
um we basically judge the last two
contestants I gave our feedback and I
chose one to invest in so we actually
took care of that a couple weeks ago and
and added that so people had to find out
who it is what it is why we liked it and
things like that when the show comes out
but
um I know you were like one of the you
know main stars of the show I got to
come in just for a day
um but I try not to steal your thunder I
actually loved it you um were very
direct I don't know if I can say this
but there was a group that you know
wasn't your biggest fan and I feel like
you really held them accountable which
was absolutely hilarious no I thought
you did great I thought it was brilliant
well you know most keyboard warriors uh
you know or gossipers they don't get
confronted in real life oh you
confronted them in real life yeah well I
mean you know there's going to be some
people this week maybe getting
confronted so we'll see what happens
sure well you know like when I ran into
Kevin O'Leary I ran to Kevin O'Leary
um in New York City I was on my way to
the uh to the Gucci store
um yeah I had to buy some new shoes for
like you know the the Wizards party I
went to that night right and there I am
right by the Gucci store Kevin O'Leary
walking down the sidewalk randomly with
his wife wow and so I rolled down the
window and I yelled at him and he turned
around and then I actually uh I looked
at him I said what's up ever you know
like we could cuss on this show but I
said the f word too I was pissed like I
wanted to confront him but then I went
and confronted him he was like a nice
old man it's like what am I supposed to
do you know so certainly uh you know
people have different dispositions when
you meet them in real life and we'll see
there's going to be a lot of people I'm
really interested to see
um this week on how they uh interact
with me yeah it's gonna be interesting
you've had a lot of um tension and
friction to say the least and something
that I have noticed is you have a lot of
different lawsuits going on everybody's
suing you and I don't understand why so
tell me who's doing you why is
everyone's suing you and like are you
okay like are you how are you managing
it you know well you know like I have a
therapist I go to three times a week and
talk to it for two hours
um talk through it like so maybe I can
be strong and make sure no no this stuff
is fun for me I don't I don't back down
for many of this and like I have so many
friends in the space that will send me a
message like just so you know like I'm
supporting you if you need somebody to
talk to him like bro I'm having a Time
of My Life like this is not so so here's
a situation like basically I'm being
sued uh by a class action lawsuit for
some plaintiffs who said that I did
undisclosed promotions for FTX that's
the first one uh now in that lawsuit uh
it's there's no way I end up on it uh on
the defendant side uh by the end of it
we never even had communication with FTX
never even talked to an employee all
seven of the other influencers on the
lawsuit not that I think they did
anything wrong because they didn't know
but they all did promote FTX yes I saw
that and so I'm the only one that didn't
and like my lawyers are having a real
hard time because like they can even
grasp the fact that I actually went you
saw me in the Bahamas like we were going
down there trying to get Sam we were
warning people for weeks ahead of time
um and so we think we actually know
what's happened and why we ended up on
the lawsuit which is someone
fraudulently misrepresented me
um as like maybe an agent never passed a
deal to me never passed a conversation
to me I understand you understand I
understand exactly what you're saying so
the funny thing is uh people are gonna
flip their Lids when they find out that
there's a good chance we're going to
actually flip from defendants in this
trial potentially to plaintiffs but was
that done on purpose or was that done as
part of just how these PR agencies work
yeah where they have just a ton of
influences names on the list yeah so I
didn't even know this one particularly
or this one particular agency even
existed until this lawsuit so what's so
funny is you know we got people out
there representing me we haven't done a
paid uh you know token or coin promotion
on my channel since like uh January of
2022 basically all of 2022 and Beyond we
we kind of cut all that stuff out or we
did cut all that stuff out we still do
support some exchanges and some
different stuff like that
um but we just don't do a lot of
promotions so you know all during this
period when you know some of these
people were promoting it we weren't even
doing we didn't do any promotions
between January and November of 2022 at
all uh finally brought some back but I
think that uh you know this lawsuit is
just a joke that the lawyer in the case
I'm not supposed to make allegations or
talk about him but you know I can't say
what we talked about in court in my
hearing uh this harassment hearing
supposedly uh is that he absolutely lied
in court uh and and said to the judge
that he believed that I had called him
death threatening and death threatening
him I guess you would say on voicemails
the voicemails the evidence they
submitted they were literally
transcripts they were not Audible and so
like I really wanted to press the judge
I really want to press it with this case
moves on like let's hear the voicemails
because he actually used his daughter
and his plaintiff and said that they
were terrified and came to him like
scared like crying like one to buy a gun
all this stuff obviously the daughter
not wanting to buy a gun she's a little
girl but uh the uh the plaintiff uh
because he's telling them that I'm
calling and death threatening him and he
knows that I never did he knows that if
those voicemails ever get released
people are going to see that it clearly
wasn't me I couldn't have for the entire
hour he said I was doing it I was live
streaming and making videos and we have
receipts of all of it so that's the
first one second one is uh you know over
uh binance and the finance affiliate
program so it's me CZ Jimmy Butler oh
y'all are gonna love this uh I can't
remember who the other person is but
um uh oh it's Graham Stefan Jimmy Butler
was the star of the pre-super Bowl
commercial from 2022 uh early 2022 when
binance said they weren't going to do
ads during the Super Bowl and so what
they did is they actually did an ad
before the Super Bowl and it was Jimmy
Butler telling people not on behalf of
binance not to trust influencers or
commercials that would be coming on
during the Super Bowl around crypto
literally that what it was about it was
literally speaking out kind of against
FTX directly yeah and you know you would
think conflict of interest for those two
cases but I've heard through the
grapevine that the lawyers just hasn't
done his due diligence supposedly they
believe I'm one of the top Affiliates
for binance and that I'm making over a
million dollars a month with Finance
Affiliates we've made eighty seven
thousand dollars in five years between
binance.com and by and binance us on the
affiliate marketing side and so the
numbers are just so crazy he thinks he's
going after this big fish that made all
this money like you know he's ever going
to get dime for me
um you know first and foremost uh but
second of all like you know this is a
problem in America where anybody can
just Sue anybody for anything and these
lawyers they don't really have costs
because they're playing is their footing
the bill or they may be rolling the cuts
in uh you know later on if they win the
case and it's like the normal person out
there you're just constantly fighting
these lawsuits Donald Trump Jr and I
talked about it like yeah you're just
always in the Limelight people are
always attacking you they think you got
money and they want a piece of it and uh
you know come and get it yeah it must be
so difficult I I don't understand how
you navigate life how you you know you
still create content how you go to all
these conferences with all these
lawsuits going on like how do you how do
you do that oh well the lawsuits are
like especially the FCX one it's a gift
it's a gift on a on a silver planner
because I didn't do any like I never
played FTX so there's literally zero
credibility to anything that has been
said about me on that case Zero I went
under oath in my hearing and I told the
judge I had never communicated with FTX
we actually worked to prevent everything
from happening and we were warning
people to get all their money off
um and the judge was like oh you're
under oath don't incriminate yourself
how can I incriminate myself when I'm
telling the truth and I try to push that
point across to her and
um you know my attorney even was like
well you know she's telling you to not
to and I'm like what is it in this
country where like you're discouraged
from telling the truth like I think
people think like that the same way that
SEC thinks Regional investors are idiots
yeah like I generally think that the the
legal system thinks everyone who's not a
lawyer is an idiot and they're like
we're just gonna self-incriminate
ourselves all the time with you know
whatever we may might say under oath but
the reality is I knew what I wanted to
say I came prepared I said it I told the
judge that he was lying about the
voicemails and uh I said my piece uh why
was so irritated about it and it's been
great publicity for me I mean everybody
knows my sponsor state.com and and they
uh you know I wore a steak tie into
court so it's real funny like eventually
the transcripts and uh you know are
going to come out from this and people
are going to see when uh you know the
other lawyer was trying to attack me for
wearing a steak tie that's going to make
it to the internet when it's going to be
gold yeah that's gonna be crazy and I
saw you had that meeting with Donald
Trump Jr that's incredible so how did
that come about why did it happen and
what was the purpose like what was the
goal of that well you know somebody is
there's some people kind of behind the
scenes working to uh you know move
Donald Trump into pro-bitcoin territory
like I believe if he goes for a Bitcoin
he'll win because think of the
demographic and I said this on the show
uh of the average Bitcoin investor or
the average crypto investor it's
libertarian it's free thinkers they
think outside the box that's how we all
got here right so those are generally
independent voters or at least a large
portion of them your Republicans
conservatives your Democrats your
liberals like they already know who
they're voting for before the election
but there's a group of people that will
go either way based on uh you know the
candidates and what's going on in the
economy or or you know the social
environment at the time and so uh you
know what you have is a whole
demographic of you just go pro Bitcoin
Donald Trump you're gonna win them over
that's going to be enough to uh you know
push it over the top well I think it'll
be a wide margin in this next election
and I don't think it'll be able to
possibly be stolen we'll see what
happens but Trump going pro-bitcoin I
just I don't see it he's such a US
dollar maximalist yeah so like they set
up this interview with me and Donald
Trump Jr and the people we were setting
it up you know the ideas eventually get
me in front of trump uh whether it's a
public interview or whether it's
privately and I just want to explain to
him why I think he needs to go pro
Bitcoin like the fundamental
misunderstanding I believe that Donald
Trump has is that you can't be
pro-america and pro-bitcoin being
pro-bitcoin is the only way to be
pro-american at this point our system is
decaying and it can't be saved over the
long haul you can save it for a
five-year 10-year spurt maybe a 20-year
spurt like they can do some things but
overall the system's crumbling or
crumbling and everybody sees it and uh
you know the normal average person out
there is scared and with Bitcoin we've
got ways out to some of this
um I believe eventually you know Bitcoin
does become the backing for a world
Reserve currency we see all this stuff
going on around the world right now it's
kind of scary with the brics Nations and
uh dual economies and digital Yuan and
all this stuff and so like there's some
secret weapons here that I believe our
country has and Donald Trump has if he
can just go pro Bitcoin so
um that's what my hope is whether it's
private unlikely do you think that's
going to be there well I think if I talk
to him I think I'll talk him into it you
think you can oh for sure yeah I just
feel like I feel like his entire
portfolio depends on the success of the
US dollar like he's invested yeah you
know that is true to a certain extent
but I mean he could certainly get
invested in Bitcoin I mean it's not like
it'd be that hard for him to do an OTC
deal and add a large Supply become a
Bitcoin whale I'm sure you could do it
but it's really about like hey Donald
Trump your your numbers in your
portfolios they're cooked because the
dollar is cooked right now so it's
better to jump ship instead of riding it
all the way down and and you know
talking about the dxy if it breaks some
certain uh you know support here it
might rip to the downside and that's
going to be really bad for a lot of
people out there a lot of portfolios but
not bad for Bitcoin portfolios is most
likely oh it's gonna be amazing I don't
know I wish you best of luck with that I
hope you're able to do it I'm kind of
I'm kind of like very skeptical about
Trump being able to see things
differently and become pro-bitcoin but
I'm open let's see but this brings me on
to my next topic which is regulation
because right now we're seeing huge
regulation
um globally the EU today actually just
introduced more regulation um wanting to
have every crypto transaction to be
um identified which is stupid in my
opinion
um but the US how do you see it panning
out over the next let's say even two to
three years the SEC everything you know
with with Securities I feel like you're
very involved in that right now before
we hear what Ben has to say about
regulation here's a quick take that I
wanted to share with you now governments
all around the world are regulating
cryptocurrency some are encouraging it's
adoption but others are hurting it and
so I'm noticing a trend of more
blockchains becoming more compliant
because financial institutions that want
to implement blockchain Solutions need
infrastructure that allows them to be
more compliant directly on chain corium
an Enterprise grade layer 1 blockchain
seems to have all of these features on
its L1 infrastructure and it's
compatible with ISO 222
what I don't like regulation what I am
seeing is if the crypto space doesn't
become more compliant it will face
severe backlash from Regulators so let
me know your thoughts in the comments
below Are You full or against regulation
let's see what Ben thinks about crypto
regulation in the US we had a bill for a
digital asset commission uh that's
roundabout way how I ended up with all
the FTX information and when we were
trying to get funding for that uh but it
was like digital asset commission seven
members uh two lawyers two uh you know
Commissioners from the cftc and three
high-level crypto experts that we as a
community were probably having in
choosing um it didn't go through FTX
kind of like you know sabotaged
everything not just my bill they did
sabotage my bill but also they sabotaged
the entire uh crypto space
um of course you've got the head
regulator in the United States uh dirty
Gary ginsler meeting with Sam Pigman
Freedom so there's literally zero
percent chance the gergensor is not
either a criminal or the most
incompetent regulator we've ever had in
history of America yeah I mean this man
literally met with the biggest fraud in
history and couldn't sniff anything out
and it sounds like probably working
together was like six to nine months or
something yeah what was at least two
meetings over six months but what we
don't know is I believe Gary ginsler uh
you know there was a period on his
calendar that he's still not released uh
so there might be some questions about
how many more meetings uh but you know
the fact is two is enough and we do know
that like there was bribes going on from
FTX to David Berkowitz who I believe was
working with the cftc and got a promise
uh from Sam to become a lawyer for the
SEC and it happened he stepped down
earlier this year so um or maybe late
last year so the regulation got really
screwed by that now they're looking at
stable coin regulation they're looking
at uh you know more simple things than I
I think that uh you know we might have
been looking at otherwise but you know
here's a fact here's what I believe I
believe the pendulum is swinging I
really do it's hard for me to see
America going in the same direction it's
going right now over the next four years
next two years year and a half probably
when the election comes I believe it's
going to go the other way whoever the
candidate is uh and I think that the
Republican Congress is going to continue
to push Gary ginsler out
um he's got to go 100 he's the worst
regulator the more responsibility for
people losing money in crypto falls on
his shoulders than anybody else so I
think when you look at the regulation I
really believe the pendulum is going to
swing and we're going to get smart
crypto regulation the SEC just came out
and said it'll be years of course they
want to be years but they're not in
control we already know from the library
credits case or even your library
credits case yeah this is the most
important case in all of crypto it's
more important than the xrp case for
sure and the reason is is because
Library credits the LBC token oh yes
I've had it yes yeah yeah so so it lost
its case for csec the SEC said it's
security well there's two phases we're
all learning this stuff right as we go
in Crypt don't like there's two phases
to an SCC case first phase is are your
security they lost that one the second
phase is what do we do now with that so
the judge in that case uh you know under
the witness uh the expert witness uh you
know John deedon's words on the
situation the judge already decided in
that case the library credits token on
the secondary Market is not a security
only the sale was and they find them 22
million dollars it just came out this
week the SEC has filed to slash that uh
22 million dollar fine all the way down
to 111 000. that shows you the SEC is
losing power uh they're not going to be
able to regulate the secondary Market
this is the only case of precedent we
have in crypto for a coin that's
actually in a sense regulated which is a
library credits token the sale was a
security the coins are not they're on
secondary market and that's a good road
map for us going forward with crypto if
you have any utility at all for your
coin then it shouldn't be considered a
security the sales can certainly be
attacked the SEC will go after that for
enforcement and money purposes but I but
I feel that it goes deeper than just
politics I feel that there's
hush
for more control you know more
authoritarianism
they're looking at Central Bank digital
currencies you know I think over 90 of
world banks are all looking to implement
a cbdc so how do you see that playing
out then versus okay so the pendulum
might be so the pendulum might be uh
swinging the other way but cbdc's are
coming well yeah Ron Sanders come out in
Florida and ban cbdc say they're not
going to be allowed here we had I think
Texas did the same thing you're going to
see a big movement of a place that are
led by Republican leaders to want to do
that now can they Stave it off forever I
I don't know like obviously we put a ban
on it in the United States uh you know
it'll be difficult for them to do it but
an interesting thing is you know I've
always said I believe Circle uh in usdc
is the digital dollar I think it is the
cbdc do you know something very
interesting happened so I went to
Washington DC uh back in uh I guess it
was March I believe and met with six
offices of Congress uh one of them was a
congressman here who I really respected
in the State of Florida uh with his
people and we had a lot of really
interesting conversations first of all
not one of these offices knew about
Library case which I thought was very
fascinating uh the sec's already you
know basically been you know voted out
of being able to regulate secondary
Market but uh you know something else
that happened along there is we were
just having like all kinds of
conversations with these you know
political minds and finding out like how
much they don't know about the heart
being the everyday of crypto and it's
it's really concerning from a standpoint
that uh you know we've got people
regulating the space even people that
have well intentious and they don't
understand crypto they don't understand
the culture uh the the industry is well
represented coinbase is very very well
represented uh you know obviously right
but while we were there something really
fascinating happened
we got invited to go to
um uh I can't remember exactly what the
name of it is but it is like a
right-wing Think Tank okay
um I
cannot remember what the name of it is
maybe somebody will uh you know come up
with it but
um we went there we met with these
people just because somebody follows my
channel and said hey come out come on
out here and so we went out there and
met with them and then while we were
there they were doing a talk on cbdc's
they're at the place and it was very
interesting I didn't listen to the talk
but I found out the person giving the
anti-cbdc talk was Alex alaire the son
of Jeremy Lair the CEO of circle who's
behind usdc interesting so I really
started thinking about that and um you
know thinking about how
there's a lot of people rising up saying
they're against cbdc's uh obviously we
know there's some version of digital
money coming for America and what if
it's going to be usdc but it's not going
to be a cbdc it's going to remain a
stable coin that would be why unless
it's like just opsec or something that
would be why his son is going out there
saying no CBDs he's no CBDs we have usdc
on the ethereum blockchain and all the
other blockchains that it's on uh you
know this will work and we might see
some kind of hybrid to where we get uh
you know some level of uh of
anti-privacy uh you know protocol on top
of usdc where it doesn't become
completely uh you know permissioned
where they can see every single thing
but certain aspects uh you know of your
daily transactions will be viewable and
they will be linked to you I just think
that's something nobody's really
thinking about is it may not be a cbdc
it could be usdc taking on a different
look uh because I think a lot of the you
know permissionless in the open and the
transparent stuff is something the
government you know does want they want
to know everything that you're doing and
they want people to be able to track
what other people are doing too so I'm
making it completely private means the
banks won't be able to get access and
see what's going on from the
government's perspective leaving it open
and all the banks have an in to watch
what you're doing without having to
create that cbdc it's a really
interesting take um I actually totally
agree with you the way usdc regained its
Peg without crashing and just destroying
and blowing up the entire industry made
me think yeah who's behind this like
who's really behind this you know what
do they want with it what's the future
of usdc so I now don't hold any USBC for
that reason yeah um but no I totally
agree with you but my only thing is I
feel that they won't
let go of an opportunity they won't let
go of an opportunity to have further
control
um and further
um influence over every single
transaction that we do we even sit with
the internet
um so I kind of want to talk a little
bit about censorship because I know it's
not just politics but it's crypto which
gets censored quite a lot I've seen a
lot of crypto YouTube channels just be
taken down out of nowhere with no
strikes have you ever had any things
similar happen to you oh yeah I mean
certainly we've had a lot of purges in
the crypto YouTube space uh going back I
believe it was around Christmas of 2020
maybe it was 2019 2019 at Christmas time
a lot of channels including mine got
taken down
um it was a problem with the algorithm
here's what people don't understand
about YouTube algorithm okay is that you
think that when they give you a strike
there's someone that can explain to you
why you got the strength and everybody's
really frustrated right because all you
got to do is tell me well there's a
little secret that you know Google
doesn't want you to know is they don't
even know why your video got taken down
if you're a big influencer or big
YouTube channel and they have a reason
to manually review it then they will put
a person to manually review it they're
just watching for whatever they don't
have a certain part that they're going
to like okay this is this good is it bad
it's just the AI is triggering the
algorithm is triggering based on things
that you're saying and based on the
inputs that Google and the controls and
a lot of stuff you're saying
um you know you know put on top of it
there is nobody there at Google that
knows exactly what you did on your
YouTube video and that's very very very
frustrating so that happened in crypto
several times like two or three times
over a two year period where like all
kinds of channels got strikes and went
down YouTube fix most of it so I do got
to give them credit for that some
smaller channels that didn't have cloud
like they just lost everything and
that's really really sad because
everybody's got to start somewhere so um
definitely when it comes to censorship
you know we couldn't say it on the
channel I got so used to saying pandemic
because a couple times they took our
advertising money away because of that
um I actually had another a whole other
brand I was doing CEO of facts on Tick
Tock uh where I really that's where I
blew up you did blow up what did you get
like five million at 3 million and then
my my account got hacked and uh it's a
long story but it's still in purgatory
like a year and a half later hopefully
I'll get it back one day but uh you know
I really blew up you know doing several
different things over there but one of
them because I was thinking maybe the
crypto thing isn't going to work you
know this is like you know late 29 19
the depths of the market when I started
that Tick Tock account but I started
growing it and doing different things
one of the things was I covered the
pandemic and at the beginning I was
scared at the beginning I thought like
you saw this stuff coming from uh you
know Spain and Italy and you're like oh
this doesn't look good like it's coming
to America like people are dying in the
streets and it gets here after about a
month everybody's like hold on a second
like these numbers aren't quite matching
up and on Tick Tock you know it got to a
point where you weren't allowed to talk
about that stuff on there and so I did a
daily show every single day where I gave
all the numbers and talked about the
breakdown of what was really going on
and uh I never could get any of those
videos on YouTube uh you know in the ads
program they would remove them because
simply talking about covid
was discouraged they didn't want you to
talk about it of course unless you're
fear-mongering they love that and I
think this goes back to your point
um you know hinting at the Wes certainly
right there is this movement to
kill Western Civilization that's what
they won that's why there's really
nowhere we can go that's safe because
they want to crush our way of life
everywhere the elites want to stay the
elites they want the the you know the
plebs to say the plebs I guess you know
so to speak that's why they're looking
at changing their credit investing loans
to make them tougher while like I'm
working I'm going to stay bill in
California to make them easier they
don't want you to be able to win and so
when when you look across the world and
you look at this plan they've had this
great reset plan
it failed the great reset plan has
failed in the last Davos the world
economic Forum tons of questions about
it started to see them changing
direction I think that they were very
bold and thought they could just
broadcast this plan and not hide it and
that they could just run over us and the
internet the modern printing press
wouldn't allow it now everybody's
talking about everybody's working
together we don't want to see that great
reset stuff I think now they're going to
kind of go back in the weeds a little
bit there's going to be like a different
angle that they're going to pursue we
may not see coming we may be looking at
the world economic Forum uh you know
great reset and stuff still and it's a
distress exactly but I think there's
something the fact that we all know the
term great reset that's their plan that
tells me that they're probably going to
do something different and they said
they said that the world economic for
him they said that their their agenda
had not been working I think that
um they were surprised at how as you put
it the the internet the new printing
press didn't allow it that's such a nice
way to put it
um but that the footage off the gas
though in my opinion they're just going
to have to change strategy yeah I mean I
don't know whether climate change is a
way of doing it I don't know whether the
whole like you know trans thing is a way
to get to the kids and indoctrinate them
and destabilize the Next Generation I
don't know
um but it's happening through censorship
online it's happening through the money
um and you know you mentioned library
and obviously they came in and shut
Library down
um but they were great because you know
they were this decentralized platform
where you can say all sorts of things
you know there's Rumble but Rumble
concerns me because it's not
decentralized you mentioned Tick Tock
but Tick Tock now you can't even say
cbdc on Tech talk I've been shut down a
million times you've got to say Andrew
Tate on Tech talk did you know that well
when I talked about Chinese censorship
of I think it was like the the riots
that were up in Minnesota and
Minneapolis uh you can't you know the
guy's name that uh you know the cop
killed up there and those when the first
riots were going under and all that
stuff and it was really bad and I I was
like couldn't believe that we were
seeing all this footage from that live
in real time basically on Tick Tock and
I said something the effect of like you
would think with you know China being in
control Tick Tock with Chinese
censorship that this might be something
that they would not want people to see
but good for China they're letting
people see this and just mentioning
censorship and China together on Tick
Tock permanently got me shadow banned
and blacklisted on Tick Tock yeah which
is crazy so out of Interest how
interested are you in other
decentralized projects there's one for
example which I really like kutombina so
they're building a decentralized
internet so anyone anywhere in the world
is able to access this internet and it's
a full infrastructure VPN privacy coin
whatever it is would you be interested
in trying something like that well
certainly I mean privacy is something
that is gone right now you know um uh I
was actually in Estonia a couple weeks
ago or last week and I talked we had a
policy Roundtable with a lot of the
regulators and government officials a
lot of business owners uh you know the
integrate blockchain some experts from
different areas
um you know in there was uh you know a
guy there that was talking about
um you know all this and the
decentralized internet in privacy and uh
you know he said that basically
uh you know people
don't see what has been taken from us
but they said that when it came to Al
Qaeda okay so Al Qaeda was actually
trying to launder money through I
believe it was decentraland uh with the
metaverse the crappy metaverse platform
right
um and it wasn't just decentral and some
of these other metaverses Al-Qaeda was
going into them and trying to uh money
launder well something happened the
first year they observed it uh there's a
guy from Norway unbelievable guy
um he they're all up in uh his it works
for Ernst young in Norway they're all up
Indy Central land and they know how
crappy and terrible it is uh but they
discovered that Al Qaeda was going in
money laundering 50 million dollars uh
three years ago two years ago the number
was 25 million dollars and then last
year the number was Zero oh wow and the
reason why is because crypto is
traceable like it's not what everybody
thinks it is outside of Monero and maybe
a few other privacy coins that have
really uh pirate uh pirate chain ones
are really stuffed to their guns are
restructure their cannons
but but the fact is is that uh you know
when you look at all of you know which
by the way Al Qaeda actually launderers
money now through Roblox I do they oh
yeah what they'll do is they will go
inside of the game and ten dollars at a
time they will go to a random person in
the game probably a kid or you know
teenager and and they'll say hey I've
got ten dollars can I give it to you and
then you give it right back to me and if
they say no or they question it they
just walk away and they go find the next
person that's actually where they
started doing a lot of their money
longer I found that out as well which is
you know really really insane
um but you know when you look at
blockchain
this is why Elizabeth Warren is so
stupid I call her powwow Chow right
because she plagiarized a cooking book
from Native Americans uh back I think
maybe about 20 years ago or so uh
literally down to the line where it said
uh one Teflon pan or whatever Teflon pan
I don't cook I'm just gonna be honest I
make a mean bowl of ground beef that's
about all I do maybe a bowl of cereal uh
but the the Teflon pan specifically
stole it word for word even though it
wasn't even necessary to put it in there
it's just so disingenuous and
inauthentic and you know she's like
attacking crypto saying we're all
criminals and everybody that uses it uh
you know is breaking the law no normal
person would need privacy or need you
know uh you know those kinds of
protections and it's just absolutely
asinine uh we see what they're doing
they're trying to take away all of our
privacy they're trying to uh you know
make it to where all crypto is painted
as you know criminals and money
laundering it's just simply not you know
Jay analysis said it's like listen 7.1
percent of all transactions and so I
think it's time we really start looking
at the real frauds in this country and
it's the people like Elizabeth Warren
people like Gary Gensler uh the people
that work for the banks the people that
funnel questions to the SEC so they can
have you know study time to figure out
how they want to answer it you see what
happens in a real-time hearing when the
Republican Congress went after Gary
ginzer when he didn't have the questions
um so ultimately I do think that privacy
is very important I think we're going to
see a lot of protocols a lot of vpns
come you know come into into play here
but countries don't like you being
private and they're going to do
everything they can of course there's
the bill maybe trying to outlaw vpns or
whatever it was a couple weeks ago or a
couple months ago so everything is
changing very very fast and
um I think that it's definitely you know
an area that we've got to learn a lot
more about absolutely given everything
that we've spoken about we need a
solution yeah and I'm so excited that's
why I'm excited about what Tommy's
building I'm excited I also like Monero
as well I'm a big fan of privacy so yeah
no I'm really excited about all of that
now it's been a huge week in the crypto
Market
um I've seen you Tweeting and we're
gonna get to hashtag Ben in a minute but
before we do I want to get your take on
what is going on with these coins
these meme coins they should be tweeting
about Pepe like what caused this run and
were you holding any Pepe can you tell
us did you make any money on Pepe made a
lot of money yeah let's hear the whole
story I turned two weeks into uh 200
000.
and then parlated into some uh some
gamblingofstick.com where I won a bunch
more money I bought a board eight but I
bought a Rolex there it is just just
this week well no it's about two weeks
ago when I was here for the hearing okay
so I went straight from the hearing up
to Aventura Mall after after visiting
the mid-tier designer mall and went to
the Aventura Mall and they just happened
to have one Rolex in the Rolex or you
know they don't really sell Rolex as a
Rolex store and so the mid-tier designer
a mall that's right over here uh said
that I would never be able to find one
in the store and then an hour later I
found one I told him I would be able to
do it so uh but anyways I went up there
and and had some fun and got that bought
some you know Gucci stuff and uh you
know put a lot of money back into meme
coins and then they continued to Roar
and uh but what happened what caused
this pump yeah so that's a great
question what people have to realize is
I I would just say this I don't like it
when people call Meme coins coins
and the reason for that is is coins
were around before meme coins were a
popular Niche okay so I had this
discussion on tour of spaces the other
day some of these people are new they're
brand new to crypto
um they're brand new nfts mean coins are
not crypto they don't have utility and
that's okay if they want to use them
like gambling that's okay I had a lot of
fun doing it myself but it's not crypto
it's not pushing the use case forward
it's like the meme stops AMC is never
going to be viable company okay
Blockbusters never gonna be a viable
company yeah you know uh AMC GameStop
there none of them are going to be
viable companies however people had fun
with it and they rolled it like a you
know a roulette table roulette wheel and
um you know some people got off at the
right time and some people lost uh when
the controls from the hedge funds came
in
um but you know and we really saw how
dirty the system is then you know when
uh you know Robin it was supposed to be
for the people and they were selling all
your data to the hedge funds to know how
to counter trade you so uh you know that
guy's enough for the people yeah that
guy Vlad he's a sketchy character I
don't like what they did at Robinhood
either but
um you know I think when you look at
meme coins that's what mean coins are
they're a crypto Casino we have a
portfolio we show every week several
examples of portfolios that we've set up
to that our audience can mimic if they
want to not Financial advice but if they
see it and they they like what we put
together certainly we had a lot of
questions about uh you know how to buy
the coins we talk about and stuff like
that and I'm gonna major coins we got
one we call the crypto Casino portfolio
we put hex in there we put nosecoin in
there we put Sheba in there
um and we put Pepe in there and we end
up putting probably way too many meme
coins in there
um I got a little probably in over my
head with the meme coin game as I was
making good money with it but I was
making money but the audience wasn't
necessarily because it's always a game
of 50 50. have to be we're gonna make
money have people are going to lose
money in trading so when it comes to
meme coins like I think we really need
to make a differentiation between like
coins that have utility right which
are smaller projects that haven't really
made it to the point yet where you think
they're going to be a viable project
down the road they're not on level
cardano they're not on the level of you
know algorand or you know Solana hold on
can we take a pause sorry
um they're not on that level yet and so
people don't know if they're going to
actually be able to realize their use
cases and of course 2017 we had all
these icos the last bull market we had
all of these launch pad projects and
most of them go to zero we know that but
they at least have white papers and
they're trying to do something now
whether or not the teams fully intend to
do what they say they're going to do is
a different story but ideally these
projects that people consider to be
coins if they have utility to them then
down the road they can realize that
utility if the project is successful
they kind of move to a different
different area of course your Bitcoin
maximalists call them all coins but
with meme coins
they're never they're a totally
different category they're just based on
community hype and so when you look at
the price of these things it's just a
game of when can you get out before
everybody else does and with Pepe I
started noticing like a lot of hype
around it that I had not seen since
Sheba well since Bonk but Bonk was on
Solana so it was never going to go
anywhere present Sheba the same kind of
hype and we've seen it's risen to the
number three mean coin I got in I
believe it was uh April 17th it was
launched on the 14th I was in like well
under 10 million dollar market cap
um and it was definitely really exciting
because I don't really invest in coins
and I did and it worked out and I took
profits and I showed people how to pull
out your investment your original
investment and have a moon bag but some
people still lost because they don't
know when to get in by in the red sell
in the green so simple behind the rad
set in the green but here's my thing how
did you know Pepe right like you said
okay this community and this hyphen all
this stuff but how did you know that
Pepe was the one that was going to pump
like do you have to know people is there
like a special telegram chat like how do
you get in the know about these meme
coins yeah so like I don't like I'm not
in any of these groups like I've never
been in like some kind of group that was
meant to like pump something or insiders
talking about something like I know
that's what the Zach Morris stock Trader
guy was doing I've never been involved
in any of that okay back in 2017 when I
first came into the market uh you know I
at the altcoin market uh I joined a
group I think was called like crypto
whale pump and dump something like that
and the whole idea of it was I was just
an investor at this point like I wasn't
anyone who made content and I went into
that group and I was like oh my gosh
this is so cool they just make the price
go up and you jump in and you make all
this money and it's so easy they even
tell you when to buy it and sell it okay
so I joined that group and I learned a
hard lesson like a time or two
um where I bought what they said to buy
when they said to buy it and I went to
sell it when they said to sell it but I
couldn't because
they had already sold all their coins
and I was the loser right I lost the
money there
um so I've never been involved in any
that was my only you know foray into
that world and it's not somewhere I want
to go and so for me when it comes to
figuring out Pepe what made a difference
it's the experience of being in the
culture of crypto uh you know I've been
in crypto for 11 years my second decade
in crypto uh now which is a really cool
thing I love to say like it's pretty
wild
um right and I've got this experience of
being able to watch crypto Twitter and I
just know when things are different and
so like with Bonk Bonk was one that
definitely felt different but it still
was associated with Solana so even back
then I said take a flyer on it but it's
probably not going to move like you know
Sheba did right now with Pepe there are
certain counts that I watch and just say
like okay this guy's talking about
accounts okay well okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna say him again I've said it a lot
of times on my channel I flex him a
little bit there's a guy his name is
Daniel his account is at Value in time
okay
so me and him he came to a meet up one
time and took a picture with me and it's
a goofy looking photo and he shares it
everywhere and it's real funny and one
day we got into it on Twitter because I
didn't realize it was a guy who liked me
poking fun at me I thought it was
somebody just attacking me like normal I
attacked his lack of facial hair okay he
might have looked like he had some pubic
hair on his chin I don't know he's got
it fixed okay he's a nice guy but he is
in that djin like nft uh you know Meme
coin world and he's not in special group
no I don't know I can't say for sure but
I don't believe he's in special groups I
think he just is that plugged into the
community so I started watching like he
started talking about checks checks was
an ft uh you know uh nft project that
started moving uh kid called Beast was
one started moving and I just got tired
of watching these nfts I mean coins that
he talked about move and not and not
having a position I said okay start
talking about Pepe within 24 hours I saw
other people start talking about it and
it was just as simple as I started
paying attention it was not just a
ticker that would come across my feet
and I wouldn't pay attention to whenever
I saw it it's like okay who was talking
about this what are they saying why do
they think this is going to be such a
big deal and you know I decided to throw
like I said two Ethan to it and it was a
really good financial decision uh for
sure
um but it really is just that experience
of seeing what's different who's talking
about he's certainly not the only one
he's become a pretty good friend of mine
um at least virtually uh you know we
have it hopefully he'll be here this
week and get to see him in real life but
um I think that if you have certain
accounts that you follow that you've
seen be successful you know just kind of
like put your eyeballs on them when
they're talking about stuff instead of
immediately piling in or instead of
ignoring what they're saying why don't
you take a step back and look at what
they're doing and look what other people
are doing and do research and figure out
if it's something that you want to get
in but remember meme coins and really
nfts to some extent are or if I gambling
at this point um I think that'll change
in the bull market there will be some
actual you know analytics that will tell
you you know this project might be
better than this one but right now
that's where we're at and there's a lot
of liquidity that needs to move from the
sidelines into crypto if you really want
to know what I heard like like what I've
heard and what I believe about this meme
coin pump is the meme coin Mania has
been driven actually by VC money VC
companies or VC funds that want to get
back into crypto in a big way for the
next Bull Run who might have been
sitting on the sidelines and missed the
bottom and they're using the meme coin
they're pumping the meme coins in order
to get liquidity for themselves to
bridge back over to the real world of
crypto where they can get back into the
projects like cardano and ethereum and
uh you know binance coin and polygon the
whole nine yards what confuses me is how
do you know when to sell because you
said you know it's basically like
gambling and it really is especially
when there's just no utility and it's
literally just a meme coin so how do you
how do you know when to sell when it
starts going parabolic you sell correct
me if I'm wrong but I feel like you know
you could sell after a 2X yeah and you'd
be like wow but then you miss a
potential 5 10 or 20x so do you need to
have like a strategy in your heart where
you're just like you know a 2X would be
really good for me and if I take that
that's enough and I don't need the 510x
like like what do you how do you
mentally
um navigate when to sell oh certainly
this is a really great question because
this is something that I I talk about a
good bit so let me back everybody up to
when uh I was first starting to get
bigger on YouTube I did my channel for
two years and nobody watched and uh you
know worked very hard I'm making two
videos a day I just thought like nobody
cared about my opinion in crypto it was
kind of what I felt like however I
learned like it just wasn't that great
at making videos back then so I got
better at making videos uh in in 2018 I
went full-time crypto and I wasn't
making enough money to justify that me
and my wife and my kids we sold our
house and we use that money to kind of
get by and some side hustles for a
couple years and I promised my wife that
when I got into crypto full time the
reason was because I was tired of living
paycheck to paycheck and I wanted to own
my own home with cash I didn't want to
pay a mortgage I didn't want to have to
worry about like am I going to be able
to pay it this month because I'm willing
to paycheck to paycheck and so in 2020 I
had a really hard decision in front of
me which is uh you know I had a home
that I promised my wife we've been in a
rental for almost two years by year in
you know two-thirds of that point and I
was coming up on that two-year deadline
and I had enough money in crypto to
where I could cash out I could buy a
home like we live in the Atlanta area so
like we have good housing prices so like
a 3 000 square foot house you know it
was about 275k is what we paid for it uh
you know back back uh in uh I think
September of 2020 and it would have been
so easy for me to leave all the money in
crypto and just say well I don't want to
sell because if I sell then you know I'm
not going to be able to realize the
maximum potential of the portfolio
but I got what I wanted I did it I met
my goal I got there and so I was able to
do that and still have like at this
point like I pulled all my money I think
I only had about 100 to 120k left in
crypto at that point and that went in
set from September to New Year's that
climbed all the way to a million dollars
or became a millionaire for the first
time in my portfolio I believe it was
like on New Year's Eve of uh 2020. so we
had into 2021 and so the message here is
set limits for yourself set goals for
yourself but when you get there don't
don't change your mindset like don't get
greedy I did it and there was a big
accomplishment when you have targets for
where you want to be in your life and
where where you want these gains to go
with these coins you're investing in
they don't go up forever like if you say
hey I want to change my financial
situation and a 5x is enough to do that
for you then take those profits nobody
ever you know feels bad for taking
profits uh down the road there's no
shortcuts uh you know you got to learn
you gotta do it the right way but you
have to set those limits for yourself
and then follow them or else you're
going to end up being too greedy I I
don't like this mindset of and and look
there's a personal preference certainly
there are people out there that are like
this but they look at every single thing
they do as an investment like my
Lamborghini is not an investment my
Lamborghini is a sports car because I
want to drive a freaking fast car that's
bigger and better than everything else
on the road right I enjoy that right
like I like to buy a designer clothes
other people like to travel around the
world and that's where they spend all
their money on and people don't seem to
judge those people right but people
spending on material possessions or
whatever you know that they're they seem
to be like judged a little more harshly
on uh you know where they want to spend
their money but the point here is
is that
everybody's money is not yours to worry
about yeah right you got to worry about
your own situation and people attack
things differently there are people out
there that will buy a Lamborghini and I
I believe these people a lot of times
they're too poor to have a Lamborghini
in real life if you have a Lamborghini
and you won't drive it or you have a
Ferrari and you won't drive it
then I guess just an investment like why
are you so scared like why don't you
even get in the first place you know
maybe you did buy it because you wanted
to appreciate and sell it down the road
and I get that everything I do in my
life with every single dollar I have is
not an investment yes part of that money
that I put into that house was an
investment on the on the housing the
real estate but that's not why I did it
I did it because I promised my family at
home you know so I let kind of like
fundamental real life situations Drive
what I do with my money
um and then you know certainly there
will be a lot of people that want to sit
out there and judge it but you can't
squeeze every penny out of everything
it's impossible we all look at our
portfolios and say during the bull run
you know what can it get up to it may or
it may not get to those numbers but the
point is there's only one moment in time
during a market where your portfolio is
at the very very very Peak there's one
moment it's not an hour it's not a
minute it's a moment where it flashes up
there whatever coins you have they might
be pumping on that day or Bitcoin
whatever and then they come down
got to know how to sell and take those
profits with meme coins when the prices
go in parabolic you got to pull out
you've got and we did several videos on
my Channel showing people this right but
of course nobody wants to talk about
that they just want to say you talked
about meme coins we showed people we're
pulling money out of them and taking
profits and I wish that more people had
done that I had a guy who messaged me a
very hateful message but a very hateful
post he was a friend someone who had
worked with FDX case and he actually
um he said I bought the top of Pepe and
you I sold the bottom of it to get in
bincoin which was this coin that was
pumping and you know I'm taking over uh
but he bought the top of it and then
sold the bottom of it and he was mad at
me for it I'm like bro you can't you
can't be mad at me because you are a
consistently bad Trader that works off
emotions that always goes at the top and
sells the bottom and those people just
seem to perpetually do that you got to
break yourself out of that mindset
um and understand take the profits where
they're going up don't regret it just
don't live with regrets yeah that's
really great advice because I'm terrible
when it comes to selling like I am so
bad at it that's one thing that I didn't
do very well would you show me your
portfolio and I'll sell it off for me
not right now I'm waiting for the I'm
right now
now I'm waiting for the halving to come
and go and then I'll and then I'll take
some profits but no I you definitely
need to have a plan you definitely need
to think okay well this is done x amount
of percentage will that change my life
if that will change my life and allow me
to perhaps even reinvest it back in then
you should definitely do that and that's
something that I need to do I'm just
terrible at it
um but you mentioned uh Ben Coyne so I
saw this going through Twitter explain
this to me like did you launch it you
didn't launch it but you're taking over
explain it yeah so like
look a lot of people are very close to
me they tell me all the time they say I
talked about this on a Twitter spaces
they they say that I don't realize the
power that I have sometimes when it
comes to things that I talk about and
things that I give awareness to and I
think that I can just have fun on
Twitter and like I just can't like for
instance uh you know there was a meme
coin that we want to put in our crypto
Casino portfolio but we like the
community and we're we're going to hold
it whether it goes down or up and that
project is called Suka I just like the
guys who founded the token they're
always messaging me and they've kind of
grown on me I guess kind of the same way
that uh you know like maybe maybe a
virus grows on you or something I don't
know
oh you do okay right so uh the point is
is that I decided I was going to finally
throw some money in there and put it in
that coin and I'm not gonna sell it I'm
not treating it like the other meme
coins or if it goes up I'm going to sell
it we'll just see where it goes but the
point is I made a tweet about that
community and also the W the Wall Street
bets classic Community yeah because
there was a big snafu people thought I
didn't know how to use metamask I do
um but basically uh there was a snafu
with a problem with metamask that day
and so I accidentally flooded the coin
and so I committed I would keep that
investment as well
um in that so I tweeted about Suka in
wsbc saying I'm going to be holding
these two in my portfolio I was moving
them out of a personal and into our work
portfolio well I misspelled tsuka I
spelled it t-s-u-a-k-a
within an hour there was a new project
launch called suaka and there were news
articles about it it went to a million
dollar market cap based on my typo
um and so you know it's one of these
things where it's like a lot of weight
and a lot of responsibility I'm a crypto
guy I should have the right to talk
about crypto and not have to worry about
how everybody perceives it at all times
but I'm in a group called Bendel it's on
telegram I got invited this group maybe
about a year ago or so and it's all
people with the first name Ben
that are in crypto okay there's like 140
of us what'd you realize if you've ever
been around a lot of people with your
same name no nothing most people have it
okay all bins are the same right like
we're all a little fiery we're all a
little creative we all make dad jokes
yeah yeah it is really funny like the
chat's hilarious just seeing that we're
all kind of the same so I was in this
group and one of the guys that was in
the group I guess when you joined the
group I thought you kind of like docked
yourself uh his name was ben.eath he
decided he was going to launch a Ben
coin out of that group now it's called
been it's called bin Dow it's not a real
Dow we also call it only Ben's you know
yeah so he launched this coin and he he
sends me some and he says hey man like
you think you can tweet about this like
yeah sure I can tweet about it like not
from a financial investment standpoint
but like yeah I support you you know
you're in the group like you know you
seem cool whatever like I'll give you a
little tweet it's funny it's from the
group hashtag Ben and so I tweet about
it and then I go to sleep like my
sleep's all crazy because I'm in Europe
at this point I didn't go to sleep about
9 A.M that day and I slept about three
from when I went to sleep to when I woke
up uh that thing went from a 440 000
market cap to 20 million dollars and
there were articles from respected
crypto news organizations like who well
I can't I can't remember the names of
the ones that had posted them to be
honest with you but they literally
approaching articles why I slept that I
had launched this coin I had nothing to
do with launcher coin the sale I didn't
even know there was a sale until the
next day when things blew up and people
were saying like no you don't know there
was a sale I didn't know so who launched
it the the other best yeah and um you
know a lot of people know he launched a
second project
um but that's not important right now
what is important is that once I woke up
I said oh no what have I done you know
like I said invest in yourself I'm
investing in Ben like I meant it is a
satirical joke like I'm investing in a
coin that has my name because it has my
name no the impact that would have had
I'm telling you I never dreamed I I
really I know it sounds naive sometimes
but like like I forget I just can't fun
you know like I forget that everybody is
especially because it was in the middle
of this mean coin Mania and everybody's
not enough fun you have a million photos
you can't have fun yeah exactly exactly
I don't know what the number is where
you can't have fun anymore no somebody
that's that's a good that's a good point
somebody actually told me from 50 000
followers upwards you can't have fun oh
it's from 50k onwards yeah that that's
also when like it stops being fun yeah
because that's when you get so much like
hey apparently it's 50 to 100K anything
I love it it doesn't bother me at all
yeah I know it it drives you yeah I've
got a chip on my shoulder and you know
that's probably why I'm successful and
um or it's driven a lot of My Success
for sure
um you know I don't want to tell the
story about Amanda Biffle Breaking My
Heart in the second grade
you break a heart no she broke my heart
on Valentine's Day in second grade 1992
and I've been angry ever since I'm just
gonna say it I love how I wasn't born
then okay I love how I wasn't born then
but you've been angry ever so without
her we wouldn't be here yeah bro
probably not bro probably not she just
would have given me a Valentine's Day
what's her name her name's Amanda Biffle
oh Amanda yeah I'm sure she's married
it's not the same last name but it's a
funny I talk about a lot it just was a
real person in second grade in first
grade but he wasn't angry ever since
yeah I mean I got her like one of these
really nice Valentine's Day cards I had
the sucker on it that stuck into the
like kind of like fold out like pop out
3D card and uh you know I went back to
my desk you were you had to you had to
you were made to give a valentine to
everybody in the class on Valentine's
Day in elementary school in America I
don't know how your experience was yeah
no it wasn't like that yeah so you would
make like this little like mailbox and
people come drop them in I gave her put
it on her desk and I went back to my
desk I was the only person she didn't
give a Valentine's Day card too I was
absolutely crushed I've been mad ever
since but the point is this is we move
back to to talking about Bitcoin no I
really had no idea I had no prospects
for like basically a couple like a
couple hours before I tweet the value of
what I owned was nothing like literally
far less than an eighth and when I woke
up it was worth like 20 and I was like
oh so like it began this process of me
like contacting but not even saying like
look man like if I'm going to be
involved in this like I need some
assurances like are you docs he was like
no I'm not docs and so I basically had
to come up with some ways that if
something happened I could hold him
accountable and so
um I was actually able to to do that and
secure some information to where
um you know like I knew he wasn't gonna
rug pull because I was going to be able
to hold him accountable like I said and
so I had assurances but everybody else
didn't have assurances well he didn't
lock the liquidity pool because
obviously he would have had to do kyc to
work with a third party company and that
was the whole thing he didn't want to do
uh so the legal people was unlocked
people had a lot of questions uh the
main guy like there's definitely you
know kind of like means controversial
some people like him some people don't
like him some people are cheering him on
some people want to see him fail want to
see him go to prison whatever
um but there was a lot of questions
about the bencoin project and I was on
my way to London from Estonia and I was
just sitting there thinking I had no
Wi-Fi on the plane 2023 whatever but I
literally just had two hours to sit and
think to myself and I just realized like
I needed to take it over like we're
gonna have the Bitcoin foundation's
actually going to be uh you know who's
in charge of it and I'm going to be the
chairman of the Bitcoin Foundation but
um I started developing a plan and so uh
later this week I'm going to finalize
that deal and we've already got it
worked out and I'm going to get all the
liquidity Gonna Get You Know 75 of his
tokens and stuff like that we're gonna
have lockup schedules we're gonna be
releasing a full road map so what's
really cool is as an influencer I can't
really launch my own project because
there's so many problems with that like
maybe if I moved to Dubai I can right
but but even then like just for me
morally and ethically like I just knew
it was something I couldn't and do and
so now somebody else did a sale I'm I'm
not legally liable for what happened
before you know we we started getting
involved in it and so what that means is
that I actually now can take control of
a project from you know we're a
community project so like I'm not fully
taking control like we're voting on the
logo we're having a logo competition the
committee is going to make the new logo
for it and that's the way I want
everything to be driven is community
based but what's really cool is like
there's a lot of stuff that I want to do
in crypto a lot of things we try to
raise money for our bill try to raise
money for political lobbying and nobody
want to get money it was a bad time in
the market sure but nobody wanted to
contribute directly to government
regulations now we see where we're at
right maybe people would contribute more
money we could have got a little bit
further and maybe you know we wouldn't
be where we're at with the the lack of
Regulation right now and so
now with this project with a liquidity
pool we're going to be able to make uh
you know Returns on the liquidity to
where we'll get those in each not even
in the bincoin and we can sell the eth
and we can fund things that we want to
do so we're going to take a four-pronged
attack at this uh roadmap will be coming
out basically as soon as our acquisition
is complete uh but there's four areas we
want to attack number one crypto media
crypto media is awful yeah okay
cointelegraph I don't know if you know
this coin telegraph's going down they
fired half of their people last week
there's all kinds of receipts of them
covering up rug pulls I think coffee
still is maybe going to do a video on it
at some point
um I've always called them cointel lie
they were started by an early Bitcoin
whale in Russia named Grisha Fishman
nobody knows this you can't look this
stuff up you only know if you're in the
industry and know people that work there
and it was always a mouthpiece for
controlling crypto well they just did
paid promotion after paid promotion for
any project they didn't vet anything
they were covering up rug pulls so they
didn't even when they fired half their
employees they didn't even give them
their Severance so every employee
cointelegraph is a 1099 employee
including the CEO that should tell
people something so number one cleaning
that up you had coindesk you know
obviously the value of that is not worth
anything yet digital currency group
behind it uh you have the block which
was paid 27 million dollars by Alameda
right so those law schools they came out
from the Block were great yes exactly so
still no one has gone back and tracked
all of their coverage of uh you know
salon and FTX over the years no I would
love to see a video on that it's it's an
in-depth video but
um you know decrypt is one I kind of
like decrypted to my knowledge I don't
think the Crypt is sketchy maybe they
are that's the one I generally give the
most respect to
um and so but we we have a problem of
bias and paid promotions driving the
news and big investors and VCS uh you
know that are on the boards of some of
these companies driving them and we need
something that's decentralized and
unbiased and so that's one area we're
gonna start attacking we're gonna start
building that out don't know exactly
what it's going to look like yet number
two is going to be what we're calling a
strategic education so we're going to be
doing all kinds of things one thing
we're going to do here is we are going
to use part of the money from liquidity
pool to buy a copy of my book catching
up to crypto and put it in every single
library in America so everybody has
access to go somewhere for free and pick
it up then we're going to try to move it
into all the high school libraries and
all the college and university libraries
as well and because I don't want people
to think I'm buying my own book up to
make money on a loophole we're going to
take all the profits we make from those
wholesale orders that we do and we're
going to roll those back into the
project so you just don't want anybody
to get the wrong message on what we're
doing we're also going to be having like
grants once once the governance side of
Bitcoin is done with a V2 contract we're
going to be making staking in governance
where you stake your coins you don't
lose them you just take them to vote and
you're able to vote on like you know
different proposals that we're going to
have so one of those is going to be like
a grant program where we're going to
fund we're going to pay for and fund and
give materials to people all across the
country that want to establish their own
crypto workshops and their own you know
educational seminars about crypto to
teach people in their area so that's
what we're going to do we're also going
to be using our bitlab Academy you know
very strategically as well you know we
hope that eventually maybe this is or
not maybe we do believe that this
eventually will be uh you know the
educational resource in America for the
education system uh so you know getting
that accredited moving into schools is
something we want to do uh number three
is lobbying right it's regulations we
want to pour money into the political
space uh and if this project is does
well like basically when you trade
Bitcoin you're helping crypto and I'm
not saying that from a standpoint like
go trade it today and you know go get
your bags I'm just saying literally when
you trade that trading volume becomes
liquidity pool earnings and that is
rolling into crypto adoption so when
you're trading Bitcoin you are actually
helping to fund pro-crypto candidates uh
sponsor Pro crypto Builds on the state
level you know Federal level at some
point
um and really change the direction of
this no one has ever done what we're
doing with a coin it's its own niche
it's going to be its own category
certainly not a meme coin number four
public awareness campaigns so what this
means we're going to do advertising
campaigns Billboards uh you know maybe
some planes with some you know maybe
some Flags behind them we'll see what
happens that all sounds so incredible
you are pushing for Mass adoption I love
it it's incredible how you want to put
that money you know reinvest it back
into all those initiatives
um I'm so excited so I you know I hope
it goes amazing I'm excited to see
people learning I love BF right now I'm
excited to see the Billboards it all
sounds it all sounds really amazing so
how can people you know follow
everything that you're doing how can
they stay in touch with you how can they
get involved okay so I'm very easy to
find I'm probably the easiest most hated
person on the internet to find
um so if you search bitboy crypto you'll
find us uh Bitcoin you can look it up on
coin gecko um you know we're currently
around like five or six hundred on
overall market cap over there a little
bit lower on coin market cap at the
moment uh but you know if you just go to
if you look up you know Bitcoin on coin
gecko you get access to socials and
other things
on there as well
um and as far as I go like it's easy to
find me if you want to know who I am you
just look up bit boy crypto you'll find
all kinds of stuff about me a lot of
it's not true some of it is
um but either way you know I'm not
afraid to speak my mind and you're going
to get a real raw authentic experience
when uh you know you join my community
the bit Squad and you know it's all
about fighting for crypto adoption let's
get it Ben thank you so much for coming
on it's been such a pleasure learning
from you hearing everything that you
have going on understanding about the
market so thank you so much for coming
on yeah it's always been a blast and I
can't wait to get you on my show
absolutely I can't wait to come
all right guys well that is all from
this podcast please don't forget to hit
the like button and subscribe if you
enjoy this content because we will be
bringing you a lot more of it